I didn't really know who you were so  before it started I Googled you on  Wikipedia I scrolled down to the  controversy section you said anime was  satanic so I was one  I was wondering if I bought your book  would you watch a season of any anime  with me well I have to watch the anime  with you you're saying yeah or just like  live How's that gonna work  um  Zoom okay I hate Zoom meetings and I  hate anime now you want me to combine  the two okay okay and what am I getting  out of this I buy your book one book you  gotta buy a lot more books you got to  buy about about 100 bucks to make that  worth it so if we started a GoFundMe to  buy a hundred books you would live  stream you watching a season of anime  yes okay I am indeed the stupidest man  on earth and the worst deal maker in  history Donald Trump would be ashamed  you're fired